this was the handshake the world had
been waiting for so much hinged on the
bilateral meeting of the two presidents
that you can almost hear a sigh of
relief
going through world markets when Donald
Trump said this we had a great meeting
and we will be continuing to negotiate
and I promised that for at least the
time being we're not going to be lifting
tariffs on China in addition the focus
here of course being on the wording for
at least the time being 50 billion
dollars at last year's g20 summit Donald
Trump said something very similar but
that didn't keep us Chinese relations
from deteriorating afterwards the EU had
much more solid results to share with
the world after 20 years of negotiating
finally an agreement with the South
American trade bloc makisu this deal is
a real message in support of open fair
sustainable and toolspace
Twitter because Twitter is good jobs for
all concerned it shows that in these
turbulent moments agreements can be
reached mutually beneficial compromises
can be found but it's getting harder the
negotiations to reach agreement on the
final communique were tougher than ever
before and lasted through two nights
straight
besides trade there was another
contentious topic climate change the
United States wanted to kick the topic
out of the communique altogether but in
the end there was just too much
opposition
in the end 19 countries supported the
Paris agreement that's supposed to limit
global warming to under two degrees and
one country didn't in these times this
qualifies as success
Spillman after negotiating day and night
it's not possible to have a nineteen
plus one statement in which the nineteen
signatories of the Paris agreement
commit themselves to the same things we
did in Buenos Aires we say this process
is irreversible it says unknown piaba
so overall the worst outcome was averted
that this can't hide the fact that each
year the g20 is under increasing
pressure under increasing pressure but
can the g20 forms still make a
difference max Hoffman put the question
to now Yuki Yoshino he's the Dean of the
Asian Development Bank Institute a
tokyo-based think-tank professor Yoshino
it seems so hard nowadays to get a
compromise that the g20 is this
institution becoming obsolete
I think g20 are looking for the world
globe representatives and looking for
the solutions for entire growth so right
after Lehman shock
everyone's looking for the same
direction but now each country has their
own interest one country is exporting
more and the success of g20 in Osaka is
coming from FRA Mustafa was focusing
much more on consensus agreement issues
why do you qualify this as a success
they didn't decide anything new they're
just guarding the status quo no I don't
think so they are looking at the
sustainable development goals and waste
plastics should be mitigated and
furthermore female participation into
education labor market and digital
information and so on there are lots of
paragraphs we can discuss not only this
year but also in future but if you look
at the difficulties they had to decide
something on fighting climate change
this is not a good direction you would
agree with that no I think it is very
important for the international
disclosure of various data for example
how much co2 has been emissions in each
country then people realize even though
leaders maybe want to consider their
exhaust so I think that it
organization and comparison of various
data that would be very important and it
can be disclosed but you agree that on
climate change it is not a good sign
that for example the United States do
not support the Paris agreement yes if
the United States will not support but
if people realize how much co2 they are
exposing to the world then that will
convince even the small children or we
export them so much so that is a very
important message to the people that's
why I'm talking about disclosure of
command data and also comparison with
other countries are very important thank
you very much professor Yoshino